l'audience de ce matin a été très courte
mais elle a de quoi rassurer des 30
salariés de l'association
le procureur général en effet plaidé
pour un redressement judiciaire et non
une liquidation comme le craignaient les
salariés dont l'association connaît de
graves difficultés financières en fait
trois structures dijonnaise se sont
proposés pour reprendre une partie des
emplois ce serait une option mais la
déléguée du personnel espèrent toujours
qu'un potentiel repreneur sérieux se
fassent connaître dont les prochains
mois on l'écouté la solution idéale ça
serait qu'un repreneur se manifeste et
10 voilà j'ai de l'argent généré un
solide jeu reprend l'association sachant
qu encore une fois ce serait la solution
idéale
c'est une solution qui est assez
éloignée dans l'avenir de l'association
sera tranché ce lundi ici au tribunal de
grande instance
en tout cas les salariés ont une
certitude leurs activités se poursuivra
au moins jusqu'à la fin de cette année